das ist halt das nicht beantworten sehr
sehr viel zeit und wenn ich dann noch
wirklich ich bin nicht youtube von
hauptbuch aber mein gott verdammt
einfach runter hey leute herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video auf
meinem kanal und zwar habe ich mir
gedacht ich spiele mal wieder dass hier
was ihr wahrscheinlich und irgendwie ist
super special ops ich spiels gerade das
erste mal seit ich würde echt sagen 34
monaten
ich weiß gar nicht welche klasse noch
mal was kann ich nehme jetzt weiter
nehmen oder super als muss ich mich
entscheiden ich glaube ich nämlich um
die stille mal
wir können hier verschiedene sachen
benutzen wir müssten steals den anderen
runter zu kicken die anderen spieler und
dadurch tötet man die wenn ich mit dem
schwert kann ich ganz normal schlagen
und ich kann hier noch rechtzeitig und
damit auch richtig machen jemand mache
ich den nieder
den kann ich euch gleich mal zeigen
damit macht dann so sachen so feile ich
kann doppel springen und hiermit mache
ich ein webshop dann möchte
wahrscheinlich einfach wenn er einfach
so und jetzt habe ich ganz schnell wie
man es nicht machen sollte will ich mir
einmal umdrehen der comdirect alle an
ich wollte eigentlich etwas erzählen
dass es vielleicht ab und passenden
modus dazu einfach mal was zu erzählen
aber ich sehe das jetzt mal einfach so
ein bisschen locker easy an rock reggae
sie hinten sind nicht alle teilnehmer
macht so eine grüne brücke das ist auch
ganz ruhig mal einfach die liga von
hinten
ja es war toll
webshop ich wollte mal so erzählen viele
fragen mich immer hey conny verwies denn
eigentlich los bei dlc zwei dir mein
zimmer hier kommen ja jetzt habe ich
frei jetzt kommt täglich zwei videos
hatte eigentlich vor ist aber alles
kommt von da hinten los
das kann nicht sein sie springt er denn
hier
ich versuche immer täglich so viel
content zu guten content wie es nur geht
zu bringen es fällt mir aber in letzter
zeit so ein bisschen schwer ich weiß ich
habe mich groß versprochen nach dem abi
habe ich zeit ist allerdings nicht so
alter das ist ein bisschen man die sache
mit dem walliser schneemann von peking
ins der dies ändert für ein typ wird
macht er denn dieser dragon gate der ist
entweder ist er richtig gut oder der
dieses mal ist einfach nicht gut dieser
schneemann
ich hätte auf jeden fall eine runde dran
ich schaffe es auch einfach mal gar
nicht ich hoffe nur dass nicht dieser
needle typ dieser typ hinter mir ist
letzter werden das ist mein ziel
daher gilt da oben auch schon die ganze
zeit jetzt kommt der donner auf mich zu
jetzt hab ich mal hier was soll man denn
da machen wird ist er mit dem das kann
nicht sein dass jeder einzeln und er hat
was macht er denn sind wir einfach alle
total scheiße oder oder wie es das
bekommt der baut sich auch schon die
ganze zeit allen jetzt ja oder daumen
runter
ich weiß nicht hätte er es kann
eigentlich sein
ich geh mal in eine andere lobby
vielleicht ist das dann besser
ich hasse das immer wenn die leute sagen
ja ich rede jetzt überlassen dann kommen
sie auf den punkt ich weiß ich habe euch
versprochen ich mache viele videos war
das gegenteil der fall also es kam zu
zwei videos am tag wenn dann effects und
galaxy kam oder manchmal auch kontakt
und galaxy oder einfach so was war da
noch mal ja viel mehr was da eigentlich
ganz einfach das ist so ein bisschen
doof gelaufen und zwar habe ich gedacht
wirklich nahm aber ich habe viel zeit
das gegenteil war allerdings ein fall
ich hatte noch weniger zeit weil ich
einfach in mensen alte eschborner
einfach in einem drin das hatte ich auch
noch nie
das ist ja und ich fragte wieder das ist
doch das kann nicht sein
das kann doch nicht sein ich bin ja so
eine mülltonne wenn ihr scheiß gameplay
sehen wollt dann kommt zu mir
jungs ich habe jemanden getötet ist das
nicht unglaublich damit muss noch ein
bisschen klarkommen mit dieser blöden
brücke ist das überhaupt ein spieler
hier was macht er denn er macht ja nix
die habe ich ja nur noch zwei leben wie
sie sind ihr 5 wenn das jetzt hier was
ist denn los mit den sachen hier tagt
hat alles ein wenig ich verstehe das gar
nicht ich wollte auch eigentlich auf den
punkt kommen alle denn da fällt einfach
mal stark runter elga ist ist ja da war
richtig richtig countdown nicht dass die
mich kennen und dass ich mich deswegen
die ganze zeit auf mich draufgehen
ich will einfach nur weg ich möchte
eigentlich irgendwas reden und die sagt
philip trug oder gibt ganze zeit nur auf
mich sein los mit dem money center cc
mit ihr kommt vom gegenteil vergraben
hier kommt jetzt jetzt steht man hier
einfach stark philipp togo kicker und
starker typ der es kaum kraft auf dem
muss drauf gehen wir wieder hier leben
verloren
kann ich nicht jetzt mal einfach kommen
wenn ich mich doch einfach mal hierhin
stelle kann nicht einfach die mich mal
in ruhe lassen dass die damals ein
bisschen kämpfen und zwar ich bin sehr
viel unterwegs wegen uni ich bin in
frank frankfurt in frankfurt wie ich
sogar auch ich bin war letzter setzt auf
den leverkusen in hamburg und sonst auch
in allen möglichen städten deutschlands
kommt in dieser philipp boy hier wieder
voll da
kommt bleibt doch einfach mal da wo du
hingehörst die hölle keine ahnung wie
ich versuche sie zu machen was ich will
alles machen was ich kann ich versuche
das zu tun
zu viel zu tun wie ich kann das meine
ich das ja noch des todes hat er hier
tot
ok
neben noch einen leben der andere 23 01
beispiel gleich einfach mal noch
irgendwas anderes vielleicht damit ich
hier so ein bisschen quatschen kann
ich versuche mich jetzt aufs thema zu
konzentrieren ist kommt einfach sehr
wenig ich habe mir vorgenommen habe auch
angekündigt dass mindestens zwei videos
täglich kommen habe ich noch gedacht
allerdings erkennt leute meinen internet
ist einfach so müll haft das ist so
scheiße wenn internet ist so blöd da
kann man einfach nichts machen so dass
tod und deswegen ich brauche für den
abbau drei stunden
dementsprechend da ich war ein upload
drei stunden brauche er lade ich immer
an dem er selbst getötet er stark oder
letztes weiß ich gar nicht brauche ich
für ein upload sehr lange und laut
dementsprechend dann ein video hoch wenn
nicht wirklich für den tag auch kommen
soll und die galaxy habe ich zum
beispiel beim voraus aufgenommen wird
wenn ihr dieses video gerade seht ist
hoffentlich noch freitag und da bin ich
auch gerade sogar im urlaub und dieses
vor produzieren ist zwar super toll aber
nur wenn man irgendwie das ganze schafft
von seinem internet her
und dann kann man nämlich auch ein video
nach halben stunde hochladen wenn man
dann vor produziert dann legt man halt
einfach irgendwie 56 videos hoch und
braucht man dafür drei stunden aber ich
brauche ein video drei stunden es heißt
sogar vor produzieren das sehr schwierig
ich will nicht alles okay ich will es
nicht alles nur aufs internet schieben
aber es ist halt wirklich auch so ich
war zum beispiel heute von 8 uhr morgens
zeitig den uni test in hamburg habe ich
aber glaube ich 90 prozent oder so
geschafft also ich glaub ich hab
uniplatz relativ safe und kann demnach
jetzt mal grob sagen dass ich mein
studium safe eine wohnung selb
und deswegen ist eigentlich alles kurze
zeit nur ich muss halt sehr viel rum
fall und vor allem weil es von mir bis
nach hamburg drei stunden unter mir
heute morgen um acht uhr losgefahren
aber ich um 11 uhr da dieser test vier
stunden team ultra was für die ultra
hier sind drei leute 3 und raus in den
schnee
wie war ich echt ich war gerade relativ
gut mit dem schneemann ein paar leute
getötet wird erster das land sie aber
brachte halt hollaus sehr sehr viel zu
tun und zum beispiel heute test um 11
uhr rtl gegen vier stunden 45 stunden
oder so da war ich um halb vier
irgendwie fertig bin dann noch zum piano
gefahren hat mir da noch was zu essen
gekauft
wenn wir noch etwas zu essen braucht es
freilich alle gleich runter erzählt
jeder 103 leben was zu essen gekauft
dann bald wieder zu hause was 18 uhr und
das war als ich jedoch nichts drauf und
stirbt einfach ich dachte schon wegen
diesem diesem doppelsprung ist es immer
so ein bisschen chaotisch
dort wo hier gerade oder verstecken
alona sommer stark wenn sich die leute
verstecken auch tot
das ist halt das nicht beantworte mal
sehr viel zeit und wenn ich dann noch
wirklich ich bin nicht youtube von
hauptbuch aber mein koffer denn es
bringt einfach runter ich bin nicht
youtube hauptberuflich ich habe noch
andere sachen neben bald zu tun zum
beispiel war heute auch das große spiel
von meiner schule gegen unsere andere
schule also was heißt gegen unser andere
schule gegen unsere nachbarn schule und
da konnte zum beispiel auch nicht hin
nur weil ich diesen blöden uni gestern
hatte
was wollen sie denn jetzt alle diese
kombi dann alle zu mir kämpft euch mal
gegenseitig
da kann ich halt nur nicht hinreicht an
diese blöden und die testate und alles
mit ein paar dinge müssen zurzeit
einfach und organisatorischen
angelegenheiten kommen so ein bisschen
liegen auf der strecke sag ich mal
und nein dafür möchte mich einfach
entschuldigen und ich hoffe dass es euch
trotzdem gefällt ich versuche hier die
bestmöglichen videos zu bringen versuche
auch so fröhlich zusammen wie es geht
weil ich ich habe eigentlich nur gründe
zum fröhlichsein weil zurzeit läuft
alles super in meinem leben eigentlich
nur das ist zurzeit hat wirklich alles
ein bisschen stressig ist aber solche
phasen gibt es halt auch mal genauso wie
jetzt gerade in diesem spiel wo bin ich
schon mal einfach hier so ein bisschen
gerade ich vollidiot können die beiden
sind sich da nicht mal ich glaube die
machen team die gehen sie beide nur auf
mich und sie fällt einfach runter soll
die andere schief mich auch ab so das
heißt nur noch ich und der
ok sondern noch ein leben
ich habe schon wieder gewonnen das liegt
an diesem schneeband kit irgendwie das
ist unglaublich op ich will nicht noch
eine runde dran hänge ich hab ich schon
hier genug belästigt und krass ich habe
jetzt einfach zwei hintereinander
gewonnen mit diesem städtebaulich
letzter ich will euch nicht weiter
belästigen ihr könnt das ganze selbst
spielen auf der rp die ich hier gerade
man nirgendwo eingeblendet ist mein plex
geht einfach auf die webseite mcvuk.com
vielleicht vergesse ich die happy in der
beschreibung dann geht einfach
www.myspace.com dann könnt ihr den
spielmodus selber spieler sehr witzig
ich hoffe ich konnte euch rüber bringen
weil einige leute mal sagte mockus kam
drei tage miteinander nur ein video und
das war galaxy das ist einfach nur eine
folge die am stück aufgenommen
was ist da los ja es sind handwerker
hier ich werde früh ins bett gerissen
ich habe einen totalen schlafmangel ich
muss tests machen wie sonstwas und habe
viel organisatorisches zu regeln aber
wenn das alles geregelt ist dann kommen
wieder häufiger videos und jetzt gerade
bin ich auch erst mal urlaub an der
nordsee
das werdet ihr dann übermorgen im
kontakt sehen ich werde mal so zukunfts
mäßig jetzt reden weil ich hoffe dass
die ganze vorproduktion klappt und ich
würde euch einfach sagen bitte seid mir
nicht böse ich muss wirklich so viel
regeln zur zeit als da bleibt youtube
ein bisschen auf der strecke und
deswegen würde ich einfach sagen die mit
wer nicht das video wenn es euch geht
trotzdem gefallen hat trotz dessen ist
relativ chaotisch war zeigte mit einer
bewertung wäre ich super cool wenn ihr
einfach mag ich da last weil die meisten
vergessen zimmer ich habe das selbst
gesehen ich habe zwar eine folge lang
nicht gesagt dass nur die hälfte der
marquis hat wenn man sagt einfach wenn
es euch gefällt dann zeigt mir doch mit
einer bewertung und sonst will ich sagen
bald kommt wieder mehr videos und wenn
ich ungesunden kommen endlich live
streams und dann kommen eh mehr videos
dann habe ich zwar weniger zeit aber die
videos laden schneller hoch dass er kann
nicht mehr machen wenn ihr versteht was
meine und sagen